It’s said that actors are a fickle, sensitive
bunch.
Some with varying levels of devotion to their
craft.
Because they’re constantly trying on new
personalities, it’s not unusual for the
person underneath to get a little weird over
time.
Wether it’s because of method acting, self-righteousness,
or just plain old bad manners, here are Screen
Rant’s 10 Actors No One Wants to Work With.
Christian Bale
In 2009, the world learned a lesson: do not
interrupt Christian Bale when he’s working.
One unlucky crew member on the set of Terminator:
Salvation found out the hard way.
When the director of photography distracted
the actor, Bale hurled a flurry of threats
and insults at him.
Audio of this interaction leaked online, and
others have since come forward saying the
actor’s intensity is unsettling.
Bale has since apologized for the outburst,
but insists that maintaining an air of mystery
is essential to his craft.
He isn’t in it to make friends, which is
good- because that Batman voice wasn’t doing
him any favors.
Harrison Ford
Being a star comes with some pretty monotonous
work.
Doing press for a movie sometimes means sitting
in a chair for 12 hours a day answering the
same questions over and over.
While a lot of actors grin and bear it, showbiz
badass Harrison Ford chooses the straightforward
approach.
Notoriously difficult to interview, Ford has
explained that he just doesn’t like answering
stupid questions.
And given how long he’s been in the business,
how many stupid questions he must have answered
by now, we can understand why.
Usually the Star Wars actor reserves snarky
comments for reporters, but has made special
public exceptions for Josh Hartnett and Kevin
Smith.
And later, Indiana Jones co-star Shia LaBeouf.
Gwyneth Paltrow
Gwyneth Paltrow isn’t everyone’s cup of
organic fair-trade tea.
Some describe her as hardworking and self-confident,
but others see the Goop queen as self-righteous
and fussy.
Often criticized for her ‘holier than thou’
attitude, Paltrow advocates for a very specific,
very expensive lifestyle.
And, not one to mince words, the actress is
prone to hyperbole.
This rubs some people the wrong way.
Rumors circulated regarding Paltrow feeling
a competitiveness toward Iron Man co-star
Scarlett Johannessen.
Leaving some fans wondering if this is the
reason we haven’t seen Pepper Potts on-screen
in a while.
Russell Crowe
Russell Crowe has opinions, and he doesn’t
care who hears them.
He’s been short-tempered in interviews,
aggressive behind the scenes on set, and even
tried to pick a fight with George Clooney.
He’s so famously unpleasant that South Park
immortalized his affinity for brawling with
segment called ‘Fightin’ Around the World’-
where he antagonizes people indiscriminately.
No area is safe from the Oscar-winners scorn,
not even Twitter, where Crowe will argue with
an average joe one day, then a multi-million
dollar corporation the next.
Rebel Wilson once described an encounter where
the Gladiator star told her to ‘fuck off’
before she could say hello.
Short or tall, Russell will fight them all!
Terrence Howard
It’s been said that “money makes the world
go ‘round” and nobody understands this
better than Terrence Howard.
Audiences will recognize Howard as Lt. Colonel
James “Rhodey” Rhodes in the 2008 Marvel
powerhouse Iron Man.
But apparently, being friends with Tony Stark
isn’t all it’s cracked up to be.
After the colossal success of the franchises
first chapter, the studio approached Howard,
and reduced his salary from eight million
dollars down to one million for the upcoming
sequel.
This move didn’t sit well with Howard- who
openly accused co-star Robert Downey Jr. of
absorbing the seven million dollar difference.
This was good news for Don Cheadle, who took
over the role when Howard left.
Jared
Leto
Jared Leto’s recent shenanigans on the set
of Suicide Squad is leading some to ask the
question: How far is too far when it comes
to method acting?
In step with his role as The Joker, Leto set
out to create some distance between himself
and fellow cast-mates.
By sending them some pretty unorthodox stuff:
used condoms, dead animals, and sex toys to
name a few.
He also studied topics like violent crime
and psychopathy, the likes of which would
make most of us deeply squeamish.
Co-star Margot Robbie has even been quoted
as saying she was legitimately scared of him.
So it’s safe to say he probably wasn’t
too fun to be around on set.